hi I'm Erik Bosse in spider-man far from
home revealed a deleted scene that
brought to us by Peter Parker himself
Tom Holland and Marvel head Kevin Feige
who confirmed which little cameo from
the Star Wars universe was cut from the
film I'm gonna quickly update you on
this detail that we missed and in case
you don't want to know but your clumsy
idiot fingers still smashed play on this
video spoiler there weren't any in case
I ruin your life okay here's what we
learned Holland said that there was a
scene cut from the film in which Peter
Parker sold all of his toys to get money
for a present for MJ he said that Kevin
Feige pointed out one toy saying I need
this toy to be in there Hollan said that
he forgot what toy it was in the past he
said that he's not much of a Star Wars
fan but he said that it was a really
nice Star Wars character and in the
scene Peter end up not selling that one
Colin said I don't know if it was a rare
one I just know that it was not one of
the mainstream ones also here the titles
of all the future Marvel movies and ever
sources followed up with Kevin Feige
Feige revealed that the action figure in
question was robot Lando Calrissian Zaid
and cloud city in the Empire Strikes
Back so in spite of being homecoming you
may remember that Peters bedroom was
covered in Star Wars stuff an 8080 or at
if you're wrong also an x-wing or if
your team at-at I guess pirate treasure
mark - wing and of course Ned's Lego
Death Star but then there were also
seven Star Wars figurines on the shelf
by the door of these the one in the
exact middle is Lobot now in the Star
Wars movies Lobot has no lines but the
expanded literary material of Star Wars
explores his fascinating backstory
he's a former Empire analyst who gets an
A j6 cybernetic implant in his head that
enhances his productivity but reduces
his personality hands up leaving the
Empire joining Lando Calrissian and
helping Lando plunder a ship that ends
up being Emperor Palpatine is personally
got but Lobot sacrifices what's left of
his personality in his head when he
plugs his head into the ship's computer
to help landowner in the Empire Strikes
Back movie robot carries outlandos
orders to help Leia in the rest escape
Cloud City and after the events of the
original trilogy he later goes on to
help liberate planets as the Empire
collapses so like most Star Wars
characters even the seemingly random
nobodies robot has
an awesome heroic back story so you can
see why Peter Parker would be so
attached to this one and remember in
Captain America Civil War Peter brought
up Empire Strikes Back as a tactic to
bring down Giants Scott Lang so this
deleted scene from far from home
would've characterized Peter Parker a
bit like Steve groans character in the
40 old virgin remember selling off his
favorite Iron Man action figures to
impress the lady toys this is Iron Man
okay I got this when I was in second
grade do you know how hard it is for
kids not open net what do I have to do
for you to have sex with me Jimmy you
dress up like door oh just a big door
I'll just I play like Iron Man
yikes hopefully Peter and MJ don't end
up having that same argument but also
this deleted scene would have shed more
light on Peters love of Empire Strikes
Back in Star Wars the silent put strong
Lobot an example of how even the
lowliest of figures in a sprawling war
can make the ultimate sacrifice play and
that nerds with robot brains and limited
social skills are worthy of action
bigger status to comment down below and
whether or not you think this scene
should have been included in the final
cut of spider-man far from home and
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
voss and subscribe to new rock stars to
breakdown sin theories everything thank
you for joining me and dressing up like
Thor or Iron Man in the bedroom
[Music]